it is October 26 2022 and you're
watching the code report just when you
thought you had web development all
figured out Along Comes an entirely new
build tool and a complete overhaul of
your favorite framework we're ready for
a new paradigm not enough men's and
disease of evil
the reality
[Music]
JavaScript it's a wild ride next JS comp
happened yesterday and they made an
extremely ballsy move to take the
world's most popular JavaScript
framework and linchpin of a unicorn
startup and totally change up the
developer experience as you're about to
see these new features are game changing
and blazingly fast but they're not
without their trade-offs buckle up
because we've got a lot to unpack
starting with a brand new build tool
called turbo pack now I know you just
switched over to the next gen build tool
V last week but a new character is
spawned versel employs Tobias coppers
the creator of webpack who knows a thing
or two about module bundling turbo pack
was built from the ground up with rust
which appeals to our novelty bias and it
integrates turbo repo to Cache duplicate
operations together these factors can
satisfy your need for blazingly fast
speed turbo pack shows updates 10 times
faster than Veet and 700 times faster
than webpack shots fired shots fired
turbo pack sounds amazing but it's
currently an alpha and I'm a bit
skeptical there's a massive ecosystem of
webpack plugins that will likely make
migration very hard for existing apps
Versa will likely need to count on
community contributions with some kind
of plug-in system and that might be
difficult because JavaScript developers
like me are too dumb and lazy to learn
rust furthermore these speed gains are
mostly relevant to Big Enterprise
projects where teams over engineer these
giant monstrosities to guarantee job
security Veet with es build is already
fast enough for most projects and it's
got an awesome developer experience
that's hard to beat you should also know
that Purcell has an angle to make money
on this by remotely caching builds in
the cloud and parcel has been using this
architecture for a long time as well
what's way more exciting for me is the
brand new routing system the best
possible router which adds a smorgasbord
of new possibilities and performance
improvements to the framework these are
huge changes that they worked on
directly with the react core team but
before you freak out everything can be
incrementally adopted so it won't break
your existing project next 13 adds a new
app directory that also uses file
system-based routing like before but now
it's all directory based along with a
bunch of naming conventions for
different use cases to create a page you
give the direct the name of the route
then add a page.js file to it that
exports the component you want to
display there nice and simple however
because it's a directory we can
co-locate extra components here as well
instead of needing to create a separate
components directory or some other kind
of convention more importantly though it
opens the door to layouts and nested
routing when you give a file the name of
layout.js it creates a UI that can be
inherited by the child routes and when
you navigate to a route inside of a
layout only the inner UI is rendered as
opposed to the entire page this is
really cool because we also have file
naming conventions for loading and error
that can render a different UI at the
component level based on its current
state for example if the component
breaks it will render error.js instead
of page.js while the rest of the UI
stays intact and this just makes life so
much easier but by far the most epic
feature in this new release is data
fetching next is what you would almost
call the official react framework now
that's our endorsement that this is the
data fetching solution for react that
everyone I think has been been waiting
for what I I haven't told you yet is
that all of these components are react
server components by default server
components are a low level primitive in
react that enables server-side rendering
but until now they've always been kind
of difficult for the common developer to
use it's a huge deal because now we can
totally get rid of things like get
static props and get server-side props
instead we can just write a plain
JavaScript function that uses Fetch and
then await the result of that function
directly in a component no need to pass
props back and forth between client and
server it feels totally natural like
you're just using vanilla JavaScript and
you don't even need to serialize data
which can be a major pain Point
furthermore you can take Concepts like
ISR SSR and SSG and remove them from
your brain the new mental model revolves
entirely around caching by default all
pages will be cached to provide the
performance of a static site but if you
want new data on every request like SSR
you can add the Cache no store option to
fetch or for incremental static
regeneration use the next option with
the number of rebalidate seconds and
what's also amazing about all this is
that the UI can be incrementally
streamed in thanks to react suspense all
you have to do is Define a loading.js
file to define the UI if a component is
still awaiting data it will
automatically show it at the component
level while rendering everything else in
the application game changing but many
of these features are clearly inspired
by remix credit where credit is due but
all is fair in love and MIT license code
but one thing next is missing is a way
to write data similar to remix forms
which I think is a really great feature
and weirdly there's no way to write API
routes in the new app directory as far
as I can tell and to me that just seems
like a sloppy loose end as I showed data
fetching looks amazing but mutations are
an entirely different story in the docs
it says the next team is working on a
new RFC for mutating data but currently
you would use a client-side component
write your mutation logic then pass a
callback function of refresh to update
any data on that route after the
mutation is complete this is kind of
similar to how things work in react
query but it seems like the framework
could provide a more intuitive solution
here overall I think next 13 looks
amazing however these are major changes
that basically make every next JS
tutorial out there obsolete even if
these changes are a step forward the
reality is that people don't like change
like people were riding in the streets
when view 2 went to view 3 even though
it too can be adopted incrementally
right now everybody's super excited
about these new features but if you're
the guy that has to migrate all that
code your initial excitement might soon
turn to anger another criticism is that
a Hello World app is still 90 kilobytes
of JavaScript it seems like it should be
able to ship zero JavaScript apps like
Astro quick and so on but that doesn't
appear to be the case in addition to the
features I mentioned there are all kinds
of small optimizations and one of them
was even inspired by a video I made Edge
functions can now be set to a specific
region and it's great to see these big
companies recognize that the shape of
the planet is not an oblate sphere but
rather a level plane and lastly I'm
working on a longer full tutorial for
next 13 which will be on my new channel
Beyond fireship so make sure to
subscribe over there this has been the
code report thanks for watching and I
will see you in the next one
[Music]